نقلت شبكه سي ان ان عن مصدريه مطلعين ان
الجيش الاوكراني سيبدا التدرب على صواريخ
باتري يطفي ولايته اوكلاهما بالولايات
المتحده الاسبوع المقبل من جانب الاخر
نقلت الشبكه عن مسؤولين امريكيين كبار ان
الولايات المتحده غيرت بشكل جوهري نوعيه
الاسلحه المقدمه لاوكرانيا واقل المسؤولون
الامريكيون للشبكه ان الاسلحه المقدمه
لاوكرانيا جاءت تلبيه لطلبه كياف وانها
ستمنح اوكرانيا قدره اكبر بكثيره واضافوا
ان اوكرانيا التزمت بشكل كبير بالقيود
المفروضه على استخدام الاسلحه المقدمه من
الغرب مما خفف من تحفوظات بشان ارسال
انظمه اكثر تطورا
الينا من البنتاجون مراسل الجزيره فادي
منصور اهلا بك فادي ما هي المعلومات عن
تلك التدريبات التي سيجريها الجيش
الاوكراني في ولايه اوكلاهما الامريكيه
الاسبوع المقبل وما خلفيه هذه التطورات
البنتاجون وايضا الاداره الامريكيه حول
مساله تزويد اوكرانيا بانظمه صواريخ
باسيوط وكنا سباقين في نقل ان الولايات
المتحده سوف تزود اوكرانيا ببطاريه صواريخ
باتريوت واحده بالاضافه الى ذيرتها وكان
البنت تكون اشار الى ان هذه التدريبات على
صواريخ باتريوت للقوات الاوكرانيه سوف
تبدا بالتزامن مع التدريبات موسعه سوف
يجريها الجيش الامريكي للقوات الاوكرانيه
على مستوى الكتائب على ان تبدا هذه
التدريبات منتصف عمليا منتصف هذا الشهر
قبل قليل مسؤول امريكي انه بالفعل كما
اشارت سيء الان فان تدريب القوات
الاخرانيه على صواريخ سوف يكون في ولايه
اوكلاهما لكن هذا المسؤول قال ان ولايه
لهما ستكون الموقع الحالي لهذه التدريبات
ولم يستبعد ان يكون هناك تدريبات اضافيه
خارج الولايات المتحده سبق ان تحدثنا عن
المانيا كحدى الوجهات هذه من ناحيه اما من
ناحيه تاكيد انطلاق هذه التدريبات سوف
يبدا منتصف الشهر المقبل المسؤول اكد ان
هذه التدريبات سوف تبدا قريبا جدا لكنه
رفض الافصاح عن التاريخ او تاكيد اذا كانت
بالفعل سوف تبدا الاسبوع المقبل لكن هو
اشار ايضا الى مساله اساسيه الى ان تدريب
على سلاح باتريوت منظومه الصواريخ
والتدريبات معقده وفي العاده التخضع
القوات الامريكيه لتدريبات مكثفه على مدى
اكثر من عام لكن بحكم ضرورات الحرب
الحاليه في اوكرانيا والحاجه الماسه
للحصول على هذه المنظومه من اجل تعذيزي
منظومات الدفاع الجوي فهو اشار الى ان
الولايات المتحده سوف تقوم بتكثيف هذه
التدريبات لتستغرق عده اشهر ولكن لفتره
اقل من
اعتاد ايمان اشكرك فادي منصور كنت معنا من
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه